Common sense tells us that when the risks are weighed, the decisions are made very differently.
When crimes against humanity...
...are punished consistently and severely,...
...the killer's calculus will change,...
...and when a killer is allowed to walk away from his crimes,...
...I believe that also tells him something.
It sends a message to the next that they need not worry,...
...that they will most likely not be held accountable for their actions.
I believe that the existence of trials alone has the potential to change behavior,...
...but ultimately, we need to arrest those who are indicted.
And the Sudanese arrest of Ali Kushayb appears to be a positive development,...
...but not if it becomes a bargaining chip...
...that will stop others from being brought to justice.
Without an arrest, we tell the victims of these atrocities that impunity is the rule of law.
Now, I don't know if the ICC is the answer,...
...and I don't know what type of court is...
...or what it would need to be for all of us to agree and make it strong enough.
I have no idea.
And after seven years of traveling into the field, I find that I have a lot I need to learn.
But I do know this,...
...no mother who had her children killed in front of her,...
...no young girl sold into slavery,...
...no boy kidnapped and forced to be a child soldier,...
...and no young girl like the three-year-old I met in Sierra Leone who had her limbs cut off...
...should be expected to simply forget.
No one should have to choose between peace or justice,...
...and that young boy in Darfur who asked for a trial deserves one.